One of the most exciting aspects of the lead-up
to Deadpool 2 was the arrival of the comic
book superhero team X-Force, a harder-edged
and more militant take on good guy mutant
alliances like the X-Men.
"I just want to say how proud I am of this
team!
You guys look amazing!
Vanisher, I have no doubt you look amazing
too."
Fans speculated on what Terry Crews' Bedlam,
Lewis Tan's Shatterstar, and Bill Skarsgård's
Zeitgeist would bring to the fight in the
Deadpool sequel, and where things might all
be ultimately going with the X-Force team-up
movie.
The possibilities seemed endless - and then
everybody died.
"Really?!"
The sequence in which most of the members
of Deadpool's new team all die comically during
a parachute jump just minutes after being
introduced is one of the funniest things to
happen in all of Deadpool 2 - and a lot of
that has to do with how totally unexpected
it was.
This was no accident - it took a whole lot
of work to keep that sequence a surprise,
and the bewildered reactions the movie earned
from audiences everywhere is actually the
entire reason the movie's creative team set
out to do it.
Director David Leitch said that he was "obsessed"
with the idea of tricking audiences into thinking
Deadpool 2 would feature some actual, substantial
team-up action, saying:
"We all loved it.
It's such a great, irreverent, Deadpool world
gag that you can't not do it."
Ryan Reynolds couldn't have agreed more.
"In order to make a great, rated-R comic book
omelette, you've got to break some eggs."
As revealed in the special features for Deadpool
2's home media release, the filmmakers went
to dramatic lengths to keep X-Force's fate
top-secret.
In many instances, not even the crew of the
movie knew exactly what they were shooting
at any given moment, with exact details being
kept on a strict need-to-know basis.
According to Wernick, many of the film's sides
- or on-set script pages - came in the color
red, making them harder to photocopy.
They were also frequently full of redacted
information, and all turned in and shredded
at the end of every day.
"It's like some spy s---, man."
The actors who played the X-Force members
were unable to see much, if any information
about their parts during the filmmaking process.
They were also discouraged from sharing what
info they did learn with friends and family.
Even their agents didn't know what they were
doing.
"David called me and said, 'You can't tell
anybody.
You can't even tell your representation.'
They know I'm in the movie, but they don't
know what I'm doing."
Rob Delaney, who played the gung-ho-but-useless
X-Force member Peter, was also kept in the
dark about many aspects of his role, despite
the fact that he's not playing a character
from the comic books at all.
"Am I getting catfished here, or…"
The production even worked to film scenes
for the movie's promotional materials that
they knew would never make it to a final cut,
all for the purpose of further luring audiences
in for the team-up fake-out.
Deadpool 2 co-writer Rhett Reese told Entertainment
Weekly:
"What the actors were very gracious about
doing was shooting footage they knew was not
actually going to be in the [movie] so we
could trick people into thinking they're in
the movie longer than they actually were.
If you watch trailers and commercials, you'll
watch Bedlam and Shatterstar out on the street
kicking people's ass.
It was all done with the knowledge it wouldn't
be in the movie."
It sounds like the filmmakers took some ridiculously
complicated steps to keep the plot under wraps.
But then again, that is the Deadpool way.
"Maximum effort."